the emperor crews are the strongest
pirate organizations in the entirety of
One Piece possessing unimaginable power
and ruling over many territories in the
new world however each of these Crews is
very unique having different Power
structures and utilizing different
strategies to achieve their goals there
have been seven Emperor Crews so far in
the story so let's go over each one and
explain exactly how they work and why is
the world government so afraid of them
for example the cross Guild is the
newest Emperor crew introduced in the
story and what if I tell you that
there's actually one reason why they're
the most fitting crew to find the one
piece although this pirate crew was
originally founded by former Warlords
crocodile and mihawk they only ended up
being Chief officers while through a
series of coincidences and a lot of luck
buggy became the president at first this
annoyed them and they were set on
killing buggy but then they decided to
keep him alive as a figurehead so that
he would attract all the government's
attention to himself the reason I said
that this crew is the most fitting one
to find the one piece is because each
member perfectly embodies one of the
three things Roger attained on the sea
well Fame and power crocodile obviously
represents wealth with his near infinite
supply of money due to his connection to
many underground organizations buggy
represents Fame due to him being a
member of the pirate King's crew and his
involvement in many major events and of
course mihawk represents power because
he's well the strongest swordsman in the
world but there's another reason why
this crew is so feared around the world
and why even the former Fleet Admiral
sang Goku wants to eliminate them as
soon as possible you see so far in the
series if a pirate wanted to earn some
money his best bet would be to capture
some the weaker Pirates and turn them in
for bounties however the cross Guild
completely changed the system and
started to issue bounties for all of the
Marine officers this created a huge
problem for the world government as
pirates could start hunting weaker
Marines for cash and even worse ordinary
citizens could get blinded by money and
betray the Marines themselves this
already happened once when the vice
admiral T-Bone was assassinated by an
old man who desperately needed money to
feed his family afterward Bucky even
took him into his crew to protect him
from getting arrested sangoku noted that
if in accidents like this one keep
happening the Marines morale would be
crushed as they wouldn't know who to
trust anymore but I know what most of
you are wondering how much are the
strongest Marines worth well all Marine
captains are worth at least one start
which is equal to 100,000 berries and
the number can go as high as 300,000
berries or three stars but for the elite
Fighters like Admirals or gar the cross
Guild uses three crowns which adds up to
the total Bounty of 3 billion berries
for each of them all this money
presumably comes from crocodile which
just makes you wonder how rich is this
guy now although there's a lot of great
things about the cross Guild they
actually have one big problem that could
eventually lead to their downfall
imagine if the cross Guild got into a
battle with another Emperor's crew
obviously mihawk would fight the captain
as he's the strongest one crocodile
would fight one of the crew's commanders
and the rest of the Cross Guild would
well get obliterated in seconds do you
see where I'm going with this the cross
Guild has only two fighters in the
entire crew of course you could also
count buggy Mr Juan and alv but let's be
real here these three aren't surviving a
minute against a series opponent but
then again what would they even need
more Fighters for the cross Guild lets
other people do the killings for them so
that if they play their cards right they
don't really have to fight anyone we
don't know much about cross Guild's
territories but as an emperor crew they
most likely have a couple of the New
World Islands under their control the
last time we heard about the cross Guild
buggy announced in front of everyone
that they would be going after the one
piece which put crocodile and mihawk in
a rough spot they can either look like
cowards in front of their whole crew and
call off the hunt or just go with it I
honestly can't wait to see what these
guys will do next I don't know about you
guys but I always like the stories in
which even the weakest characters like
buggy in this example can end up
becoming incredibly respected or
powerful there's actually a whole genre
full of stories like these called system
and if you're interested in reading some
of them for free you can do it on the
web novel website for example I've
recently really gotten into this one
system story called reincarnated with
the strongest system it's about the main
character being reborn into the mythical
world full of monsters however the
interesting thing thing is that he has
the strongest system which allows him to
constantly level up and upgrade his
abilities it's really cool to see how he
starts as being really weak and then
gradually becoming more and more
powerful literally becoming a god
warrior in the end if you want to start
reading this amazing story as well just
click my link in the description to
download the web novel app type system
in the search bar and you are ready to
go but that's not all because if novels
aren't your thing there are also a bunch
of unique Comics you can read click my
link in the description below to
download web novel app now and enjoy the
largest comics and novel Library Online
there's still six Emperor Crews left to
cover and let's continue with the
infamous Beast Pirates the Beast Pirates
were an emperor crew commanded by the
world's strongest creature kaido during
its peak the crew had over 20,000
members and kaido only planned on
increasing that number however the Beast
Pirates aren't your typical pirate crew
as they have one secret weapon that
makes them unimaginably powerful you see
the problem for most of the crews is
that only a handful of people have devil
fruit abilities which makes most of the
regular soldiers pretty weak well this
is exactly why kaido partnered with
former warlord doflamingo in order to
create artificial devil fruits and
strengthen his crew this led to the
Beast Pirates being the crew with the
most devil fruit users in the series at
over 500 although 500 devil fruit users
are a big deal there are still two
divisions within kaido's crew that hold
even more power than them first is the
toiro or the flying six a group that
consists of six very capable Fighters
all handpicked by kaido himself but even
they are not the strongest fighters of
the Beast Pirates because that spot goes
to the mighty Allstars Jack the drought
Queen the plague and King the
conflagration all three of them are
powerful executive officers and each one
has a bounty of over 1 billion berries
another unique thing about them is that
they all command ships themed around
their Zone forms which we didn't see in
any other crew so far at some point in
time kaido took control over wano an
Island full of strong Samurai and ninjas
there the Beast Pirates built numerous
weapons factories that make use of the
drunken iron ore that can only be found
in wano they also made onigashima a
nearby Island their base of operations
and even tried to move it to the center
of wano to crush its current capital
besides onigashima and wano the only
known territory of the Beast Pirates is
an unnamed winter Island somewhere in
the new world okay we all know that
kaido and his crew are ruthless towards
their enemies but living on kaido land
as a regular citizen is even worse you
see citizens work in factories for
minimal pay just enough to survive
leaving the land is prohibited and if
you try to escape you'll just end up in
prison working as a slave nobody dares
to attack one of the Beast Pirates
territories but if someone's stupid
enough to do it kaido wouldn't really
get involved himself and would send
someone else to deal with it so he can
focus on what really matters getting
drunk and I mean this guy really likes
to drink if Luffy didn't defeat him he'd
probably die of liver failure soon
anyway what's the ultimate goal of This
Crew probably just to find the one piece
right well not really their real goal is
much more Sinister than that firstly
they made an alliance with another
Emperor crew the big mom Pirates which
didn't last very long as they were Tim
Ely defeated but if they'd won their
ultimate goal was to find all ancient
weapons and take over the whole world so
who are these big mom pirates that kaido
made an alliance with well the captain
of this crew is the Emperor Charlotte
linlin aka Big mom and although we don't
know the exact numbers we can assume
that the big bom Pirates have tens of
thousands of soldiers spread across all
of their territories the crew's main
Force however consists of 74 strong
officers who are get this all big mom's
children considering she's only 68 years
old I don't even really want to know how
that's possible if I'm being honest
anyway above all regular soldiers and
officers sit the sweet commanders the
crew's three ultimate fighters Charlotte
cracker Charlotte smoothie and Charlotte
Kakui there was also a fourth Commander
Charlotte snack but he got demoted after
he lost a battle against an intruder
we'll talk about how this crew deals
with Intruders a bit later on as that's
definitely one of my favorite things
about it anyway the main territory of
the big mom Pirates is called Toto land
and it's an archipelago that consists of
35 islands all governed by big mom and
her children all of these islands are
named after something sweet and the
children ruling over them are called
ministers for example there's a minister
of yeast a minister of eggs and even a
minister of alcohol I mean something's
telling me kaido and this guy would get
along pretty well in contrast to kaido's
territory totaland is actually a nice
place to live in and a lot of people
willingly come there but there's a dark
twist although people living there are
completely safe and under big mom's
protection every 6 months all citizens
must donate one month of their lifespan
to Big Mom it's kind of like taxes in
the real world but less complicated so
what kind of protection do you get for
this well big momb ships called Tarts
are scattered in the sea around all the
islands ready to shoot down anyone
foolish enough to sell near totaland
Uninvited but what if someone manages to
avoid being seen and gets on the island
in that case big bomb has a unique
three-step plan to deal with The
Intruders firstly total land is packed
with these weird weed animated chess
soldiers who basically serve like
policemen and ensure that everything's
in order in case the Intruder defeats
these soldiers big mom will send
whatever her sweet commanders after them
if by some miracle sweet commanders are
also defeated the third step will
commence big mom will get furious
causing a storm over the entire land in
addition her entire Army including the
majority of the officers would instantly
start marching towards the Intruder and
there's no way anyone is surviving this
but how did the big bomb Pirates even
get this strong it's all to one thing
political marriages you see due to big
mom having so many children she often
arranges these political marriages in
order to make her crew stronger the best
example of this is the planned marriage
between pudding and Sanji where big mom
wanted to get her hands on German
technology despite big mom obviously
being an evil character her dream's
actually a pretty wholesome one she
wants to make a country where all Races
can live happily together but this will
never happen for one simple reason every
single Giant in the world hates big momb
due to to an incident in her past and
doesn't want to live on her Island also
she sometimes eats people which
definitely doesn't work in her favor
okay let's continue this list with the
first good crew on the list at least I
think so the redhair Pirates the red
hair Pirates are led by their Chief
redhair Shanks and are more chilled than
any of the other Emperor Crews up until
now they would just party and have fun
almost every time we see them although
they're completely Carefree most of the
time when something serious happens the
redhair Pirates are quick to act and
will show no mercy towards their enemies
some characters learn that the hard way
but before we talk about that let's see
what it is that makes this crew so
powerful first of all it's important to
mention that the redhair Pirates are a
relatively small crib and all of their
power comes from their leader Shanks his
first mate Ben Beckman and eight senior
officers even though this is the first
pirate crew we were introduced to in the
manga it's still completely shrouded in
mystery and not much is known about it
we don't even know if anyone on the crew
even has a devil fruit however one thing
we we do know is that both Shanks and
Ben are masters of hockey with even
Admirals being terrified of their
strength so what happens when the
redhair Pirates get serious well for
example when Shanks heard that kaido was
planning on joining the summit War he
immediately went to intercept him and
convince him to stay away from the fight
then he and his crew went to the
battlefield and stopped the entire War
another thing that will make redhair
Pirates Act is when someone attacks them
or any of the people under their
protection what happened to kid is a
good example since kid's attack was
threatening to completely obliterate
Samos shank's allies he instantly got
serious and used one of his strongest
attacks on kids instantly defeating him
many subordinate Crews sail along the
redhair Pirates but these crews are
extremely weak and are only alive
because Shanks is protecting them though
unlike big mom Shanks doesn't protect
them in exchange for payment he just
does it out of generosity and because he
considers them to be friends we don't
know much about the exact territories
that the redhair Pirates control but
from the recent chapters it seems that
elb the island of giants is one of their
main territories although we have no
idea what the redhair Pirates goal
actually is recently in the story Shanks
declared that they will finally be
joining the race for the one piece is
shank's real goal to become the pirate
king I guess we'll have to wait and see
the Whitebeard Pirates the Whitebeard
Pirates were commanded by Edward Newgate
and were an enormous crew with almost
2,000 members they're also one of the
veteran crews in one piece world and the
only crew on this list whose goal wasn't
to find the one piece but something
completely different back in the day the
Whitebeard Pirates were so powerful that
they regularly clashed with the pirate
King's crew these battles were described
as legendary and they would always end
in a draw as both Crews were of pretty
much identical strength even after their
Glory Days the Whitebeard Pirates were
still considered an emperor crew and
held immense power throughout the grand
Line This Crew consisted of 16 divisions
and each division had its own captain in
addition to this they had an incredible
amount of allies in the new world 43
pirate Crews that would come to support
them whenever need be the greatest
Testament to their strength is the fact
that the world government had to prepare
their entire Marine Force three Admirals
plus seven Warlords of the sea in order
to fight this massive crew but all this
influence and power was never
whitebeard's real goal you see due to
being an orphan who grew up in poverty
the only thing Whitebeard wanted was
connection with other people the family
and that's exactly what his crew was to
him one giant family he's the father and
everyone on the crew is his son
Whitebeard Pirates had a huge amount of
islands all around the world under their
Protection free of charge people knew
not to mess with the land protected by
Whitebeard because he would find them
and make them pay heck Bucky even had a
chance to kill Ace while he was sleeping
but when he saw the Whitebeard pirate
tattoo he got scared knowing that
touching Ace would mean certain death to
him and his crew although the Whitebeard
Pirates had a good run for almost 30
years it all started falling apart after
the summit war and whitebeard's death
but that wasn't even the worst part
after the war Marco the first division
Commander became the new captain and
wanted to take revenge on the Blackbeard
beard Pirates this really bad idea led
to Whitebeard Pirates suffering another
devastating defeat which ultimately
resulted in the disbandment of the whole
crew in addition other New World Pirates
claim most of the crew's territory with
Blackbeard taking the biggest chunk the
only Island that Still Remains under the
protection of the Whitebeard Pirates is
whitebeard's Hometown Sphinx personally
guarded by Marco only two more insanely
powerful crews are left to cover and one
of them are the notorious Blackbeard
Pirates the first time we saw this crew
they looked like a bunch of weaklings
who just acted tough but as time went on
we got to see just how scary they
actually are similar to how Whitebeard
Pirates had 16 Division commanders
Blackbeard Pirates have 10 Titanic
captains which sounds much more
intimidating four of these Titanic
captains are members of Blackbeard's
original crew that we saw in Gia Bas van
auger lefit and Doc Q however after
breaking into impel down Blackbeard
freed and recruited the four strongest
prisoners along with the former head
Jailer shidu of the rain but then the
Blackbeard Pirates did something that no
other crew in history managed to pull
off you see in the recent chapters we
got an official reveal that the last
Titanic captain is actually the former
Marine Admiral aliji I guess you can now
say that the Blackbeard Pirates are the
coolest crew in the world I know sorry
about that anyway all Titanic captains
have ships of their own and command a
part of the crew although this next part
is not fully confirmed yet Blackbeard
also has his own ship called saber of
zebic which seems to hint towards Rock
zeit the famous pirate who wanted to be
the king of the world the ship was
unfortunately not revealed yet and I
personally can't wait to see what it
looks like in general Blackbeard and his
crew are the closest thing to the real
pirates with their evil plans and dirty
strategies they're the only crew that
actively goes around Islands pillaging
and killing helpless civilians but
surprisingly they also seem to have a
softer side as we can see that among
themselves they're actually great buds
often drinking and telling stories
together what really made the world
recognize the Blackbeard Pirates as a
dangerous crew was their appearance
during the summit War when they killed
the former Emperor Whitebeard and later
took most of his territory these
achievements eventually led to them
being recognized as the new emperor crew
Blackbeard Pirates have done many awful
things so far in the story like getting
involved in the Rocky Port incident
kidnapping Kobe defeating hard Pirates
and just recently defeating the hero of
the Marines GARP but the Blackbeard
Pirates really seem to like kidnapping
because they've also taken pudding of
the big mom Pirates one of only three
known people in the world capable of
reading poneglyphs this makes them
probably the closest crew in the race
for the one piece because all they need
is one more road poneglyph but the real
reason this crew is so strong is because
they know something no other crew knows
you see during the past few years the
Blackbeard Pirates have been hunting and
killing people with strong devil fruits
the reason they do this is because they
figured out a way to extract devil fruit
powers from people and use them
themselves besides wanting to become the
king of the Pirates and find the one
piece Blackbeard also has another more
surprising dream he wants the world
government to recognize his main island
haosu as a legit Kingdom where he'll be
the king he also thought about naming it
Blackbeard Kingdom he probably fried his
brain coming up with that one the straw
hat Pirates starting from just a little
boat and no crew members the captain of
This Crew Monkey D Luffy has done a lot
in less than 3 years and recruited nine
Incredible Crew mates the structure of
the straw hat Pirates is much different
compared to other Emperor Crews as it
has 10 members in total there's a severe
lack of authority in the crew with
pretty much everyone doing their own
thing most of the time as they don't
really have to ask for Luffy's
permission to do stuff however when
things get serious and Luffy gives an
order the crew will immediately assemble
to fight any enemy in sight even if the
foot is way stronger than them it's safe
to say that the straw hat Pirates are
the freest crew on the sea they don't do
any of the stuff the other Emperor Crews
do like manufacture strong weapons
involve themselves in politics or wait
for the right opportunity they just do
whatever the hell they want this freedom
is a big part of the cruise most
important ability the ability to make
friends wherever they go just look at
how many people they allied with the
kingdom of alabasta everyone at Fishman
Island Ry the galila company Frankie's
family the list goes on and on also
although they're not officially allies
yet the straw hat Pirates have a strong
connection to the Revolutionary Army due
to Dragon being Luffy's dad another
unique thing is that this crew doesn't
hand out titles like officers or
commanders instead most of them have
roles on the ship for example Sanji is a
cook Nami is a navigator Chopper is a
doctor and well you get the point
although the crew is small they
shouldn't be underestimated by any means
as their combined Bounty is almost 9
billion berries also with the Awakening
of gear 5ifth Luffy has become one of
the strongest characters in the whole
series with even kaido comparing him to
the likes of Whitebeard Shanks and even
Roger but it's not just the captain
who's strong literally everyone in the
crew can manage on their own even the
three weaklings of the crew who sop Nami
and Chopper always find ways to be
useful and help in big fights during the
liberation of Dres Rosa many Pirates Who
were saved by the straw hats vowed to
serve under Luffy and form the straw hat
Grand Fleet this Fleet consists of seven
pirate Crews numbering
5,640 members in total although we don't
have the exact information I'm pretty
sure this Fleet is even bigger than
whitebeard's former Fleet which is just
insane as you all know the main goal of
the straw hat Pirates is to find the one
piece which would make Luffy the pirate
king but all of the members have dreams
of their own too like becoming the
world's strongest swordsman drawing a
map of the world or learning the world's
history as far as the territories go
only Fishman Island and wano are
officially under protection of the straw
hats but I think we should also count
every country they liberated on their
Journey this would include drum Island
Alabaster skypia dress Rosa and zo the
stra Hat Pirates are undoubtedly an
incredibly strong crew but what if I
tell you that by the end of the series
they'll get even stronger and unlock
some mind-blowing ability ities if
you're interested in hearing more about
that click on this video next where we
explain it in detail